Hello everyone. Can you all hear me
well?
All right, amazing. Uh thank you for
joining this session. In this one we're
going to talk about sovereignty.
Uh my name is Viguen. I work as a senior
developer relations engineer at Deepset.
But I want to start with a question. So
how many of you are familiar with the
term of sovereignty?
Wow, okay, amazing. Maybe I don't need
to do a lot of introduction for this
one. And um just a little bit of context
here about Deepset.
Uh Deepset is the company behind the
open source orchestration framework
called Haystack. We also have our
enterprise platform. And with those
products we are solving customer AI
challenges for big organizations like
Airbus, Bosch, Siemens, but also public
sector uh organizations like European
Commission, Federal Ministry of Research
and Technology uh and space in Germany
and other ministries as well. So you can
imagine sovereignty is a very big and
important topic for us.
So here is a like a policy definition
you can say what sovereign sovereign AI
is. Sovereign AI is the ability of an
organization to design, deploy, and
operate AI systems on its own terms. But
we are all engineers here. We are not
policy makers, we are not lawyers. So if
you if you
turn that into a technical
uh definition, it's basically having
explicit control over data flow, model
choice, infrastructure, observability,
and operations.
And um for us to understand it better, I
want to split that into four pillars. So
the first one is data sovereignty. So,
it's about where you store your data,
where does it get processed? The second
one is model sovereignty, who controls
the running models, the origin of the
training data. The third one is
infrastructure sovereignty. So, where
does compute happen? And the last one is
operational sovereignty. So, is your
application, is your system traceable?
Who can update it? Who owns the incident
response?
So, let's go into the depths of this for
a minute. Um data sovereignty. Data is
the most important assets that we have
in in an enterprise. And for us to have
data sovereignty, data should be
processed and stored within trusted
jurisdictions to meet compliance
requirements. What does it mean? So,
basically, GDPR says that your the
European citizen data should stay within
Europe. But, if you send that data to an
embedding model, to an embedding API
hosted in Virginia in the US, then you
are already losing the control of your
data. So, that's against data
sovereignty. And the other aspect is
access permissions. So, this not exactly
about how the data is stored and
processed, but if there are users in
your organization, within your
organization, that are that has access
to data that are not that they are not
supposed to see, there's also a breach
of data sovereignty.
The other one is infrastructure
sovereignty. So, where does compute
happen? It means like we we have the AI
application layer. So, we have our rag
pipeline ingestion, we have agents, uh
these the tools for the agents, and they
all run somewhere. And where this
application layer runs defines the
infrastructure sovereignty of your
system.
Um and this and there's this whole
spectrum from max control to max
convenience. Maybe you run everything in
an air-gapped environment, it gives you
the EU AI Act safe. Maybe you run on a
uh private VPC, this gives you GDPR
safety. There is also sovereign cloud,
this kind of depends on the provider
that you're going with. And there's also
at the very end there's SaaS. So with
SaaS, you kind of face the cloud act
risk, meaning that if you are for
example using US headquartered company,
although you store, you run all your
date all your application within Europe,
uh they have ability to get access to
your running data. So that's against the
sovereignty that you have over your
system.
The other pillar is modern sovereignty.
So who controls the model and the origin
of the training data?
Um so the
you should have the freedom to choose
and switch models. But what it means
that if your system can only work with
one specific model, you are tightly
coupled with that model provider.
If they are if the API is down, then you
lose access. If they increases the
price, then you also have a cost issue.
Um this is kind completely against the
model sovereignty idea. And the other
one is swappability without
architectural changes. So maybe you're
not
tightly coupled with that model
provider, maybe you can use other models
as well. But if your system, if your
code doesn't allow that immediately,
then you are although technically you
are not tied to that provider, but
you cannot just change the whole code
base within one day.
And the last one is training data
origin. So this is a bit controversial
because we don't have a way to know like
where the model was trained, which data
was used to train this model. Uh but
uh if a model provider is a European
company, then they have a better
advantage than other companies based in
the US.
The The last pillar is operational
sovereignty. So, like building the whole
AI system is one aspect, but monitoring
So, basic basically maintaining this
whole system by monitoring, evaluating,
managing is also another. Uh operational
sovereignty is about monitoring how
these systems behave in production,
including model inputs and outputs. And
in high-stake environments like HR or
finance, it requires human in the loop.
And managing versioning, updates to
models and the application layer uh in a
controlled auditable way also goes under
this operational sovereignty.
But the good news is sovereignty is a
spectrum. So, not everyone needs like
needs to be sovereign in all of these
pillars. Of course, like uh if you are
in finance, in healthcare, in high-stake
environment in high-stake domains, you
might need an fully air-gapped solution.
But if you are an enterprise or a
startup working in a different domain,
then maybe you don't need everything at
all. You're You don't need to comply
with every sovereignty pillar that I
showed you. The important thing here is
you need to know the level of control,
so the the level of vendor lock-in you
have with your system.
So, you are here in the conference this
week, but next week on Monday you're
going to go back to work and maybe your
manager or CIO comes and says like,
"Okay, now we need to make like we have
this working system, but then now we
need to make it sovereign."
Uh and in this slide I want to show you
what you do first usually and what you
break in this existing system. So,
probably intuitively the first thing
that you do is the model and you replace
the frontier API that you have with a
self-hosted model. And what happens?
Then you need to translate this whole
API logic to this new model
architecture. Maybe you need to update
the prompts. Basically, you need to
evaluate the performance of the system
from scratch. And you need to write a
lot of code.
The other one is you move private data
into the required jurisdiction because
you notice that okay, we have some
information hosted in in the US. Now we
need to take them somewhere in Europe
and you do that, but you find yourself
managing multiple databases and
instances. Then search becomes a
problem. So how do you handle search? Do
you do classification like query
classification first or do you send the
request to both of those databases and
get information from those? That's just
one challenge that comes with this
change. And the other one is you replace
manage infra with on prem and you
immediately notice how much you had
vendor lock-in in this area. You because
now you also start thinking about okay,
Kubernetes cluster management, how do I
like deal with all these
all these things that all these model
pro all these cloud providers were
handling for you? And there are also
hardware limitations because now you
need to think about okay, I have this
application layer running in GP CPU, but
now I have my model run now running GPU.
So I need to connect them in a way and
this connection management, network
management also becomes a problem. And
the last one is you incorporate
observability and tracing. I mean, if
you if you didn't have observability
until this point in your system, that's
an important issue already. But if you
now you when you need to incorporate it,
you notice that you have this fully
black box thing. So you don't know
actually what's happening in this AI
application layer. So you need to
understand now because you need to log
it somewhere so that your system is
auditable. And there's is version
control aspect. How do you do version
control for your application layer, for
this whole system that you are managing?
And I want to hear shamelessly plug
Haystack because a good orchestration
framework I think solves some of these
problems. I mean, good orchestration
cannot solve your GPU limitation, but
can help you with so many different
stuff. Uh the the first thing is uh
Haystack is has this consistent
interface. So, basically, it when you
want to transition your system from
cloud to a self-hosted application, you
can easily do so just changing couple
lines of code and just focus on the
hardware that you have and this hardware
connection. The second one is explicit
data flow. So, every input and output in
a Haystack application is typed and
declared. So, you can read the pipeline
definition all over the this whole
application
uh in a in a in a regular way and know
exactly what data was where and even in
less deterministic architectures like
agents and
uh like agents the whole data this tools
tool calls and tool outputs are
traceable.
The third one is YAML. So, the Haystack
applications are serializable to YAML
making them very easy to version. So,
you can just
after creating your application with
Haystack, you can turn it into YAML, put
it into your version control, and then
when you need to go back to the history,
you just need to go back to the the
commit and you you can see the hash.
And the last part is it's truly open
source. So, there's no black box, no
hidden assumptions. And when you need to
customize some code or extend one of the
components, you can easily do so because
you actually understand what's happening
under the hood.
And here is one Here's a sovereign
architecture that I want to show you
um today just as like a high-level
overview. Uh imagine you're building
this agent, but it needs to be some sort
of sovereign. So, first thing that you
do probably you add some guardrails
before, and then because this guardrail
needs to check if there's like a prompt
injection coming from the user input
coming through the user input, and it
needs to also check some specific
regulatory checks maybe because I this
is like a very specific agent that needs
to be used in a certain way, and you
want to check if user has this
intention. And if it's unsafe, it just
leaves the application layer
immediately. Uh and if it's a safe uh
request safe input, then it goes to the
agent. And agent here is basically an
LLM with a system prompt and lots of
different tools. And these tools can be
API calls, maybe they're connected to
your knowledge base that you're you're
doing some sort of search. Maybe you are
using other agents if you're dealing
with a
um multi-agentic systems, and there are
also MCV servers, of course, that are
connected to your agent. And agent
creates an input, so does the uh does
the work for you, and there is the last
guardrail doing a compliance checks
because you also don't want to leak
sensitive information to your user, and
then there becomes an output.
And uh but of course, like how you
design a system as a sovereign system is
a challenge. And the the duty of
Haystack here is to make sure that
everything is swappable, traceable, and
without vendor lock-in.
Um so, you know, you can work with the
right level of sovereignty uh that you
need. And here are some of the uh the
tools that I picked from
that I picked that you can work with
Haystack. Um so, maybe you uh you decide
you need like different models based on
the task. Maybe you decide that for
public data, you can steal some
proprietary models from those providers,
so you don't worry about those. But for
some of the task, for guardrails, maybe
for your knowledge base, for uh for your
LLM, you think that you need local
models running on on like self-hosted
local models from other different
providers like
uh Mistral, Google, Nvidia, and Gina.
And then, of course, uh there's
traceability aspect. And as I said, in
Haystack, everything like every input
coming to a component and every output,
but as well as the traces in the agent
is easily visible, so you can just
connect those spans to your LLM
observability tool. And you can since
there is OpenTelemetry integration, you
can also implement your own
observability.
And as the last part, there's the
storage. I wanted to pick some of the
providers who can give you cloud and
also the open-source version of them, so
you can easily host these ones uh
locally
uh on your prem.
And here is the um here is a guardrail
um
code. So, uh basically, how you connect
a guardrail or how you define a
guardrail is quite simple with Haystack.
You just start with a model provider.
For example, in this one, it's the
Nvidia chat generator. You give the name
of the model that you want to use. And
by connecting it to your LLM message
router, it helps you do the
classification. So, it checks the input,
if it's safe, it goes to the safe route,
and if it's unsafe, it goes to the
unsafe route.
And then, you add you start adding
tools. So, you connect your MCP server
that you host locally with uh with MCP
tool set, and you give the names of the
tools that you want to pick from that
MCP server. Because probably you have
lots of tools running on that on that
MCP server. You don't want to get all of
them.
You don't want to have access to all of
them with just one agent. And you pick,
for example, knowledge base search and
generating PDF report one. And but of
course like you can add the different
tools. You can add just like you can
start defining tools from a Python
function or you can connect other
components in Haystack like agent
component into a tool or maybe there's
some functionality that you define like
data ingestion or rack pipeline and you
can also convert those workflows into
tools as well. And by after this
defining all of these tools, you put
them in a searchable tool set. So this
gives you a dynamic tool search with
BM25 because you probably now have more
than hundreds of tools to for your
agent, but you don't want to fill in the
whole context with just tool
definitions.
Then there's this agent component. So
basically you define a system prompt.
You say like you're a sovereign agent
with access to multiple tools and you
define the intention of this agent and
then you put a brain to this agent.
Basically a chat generator. If you are
running this model locally on prem,
maybe you create your own custom
component saying now this is my own prem
chat generator connected to this
internal company URL and getting the
model inference from that. But of course
if you have an open AI API compatible
endpoint, you can already use an
existing component in Haystack and then
you give the tools and then you define
confirmation strategies. So basically
you incorporate human in the loop saying
that so if the user wants to submit a
request, the agent should always ask for
human approval, but if the agent wants
to use the list payment request tool,
maybe ask for a permission first from
the human and then you can use this tool
as much as possible,
as much as you want in this whole cycle.
Then you bring it all together. So, you
start defining your pipeline. You first
add the component as a tracer that
connects to your
LLM observability. Then you put the
input guardrail. You connect your agent,
the output guardrail, and you you can
just run this agent saying that pull the
outstanding payment request for Q3 and
generate a PDF for me. And by using the
tools that this agent has, it creates
the PDF for you and saves it under this
directory under this name.
So, with that,
I want to give you just like when we are
coming to the end of the presentation, I
want to show you a checklist. So, if you
want to check if your
system is sovereign, you can you can
take a look at this question. So, you
can think about can you swap models
without changing the application logic?
Do you have reproducible run logs stored
in a complying way? And can your team
respond to an incident without calling a
vendor like one of those hyperscalers?
Thank you for joining the session.
And you can get the presentations and
ask the questions to me by filling in
the the form. And you can also find me
on social media if you want to connect
there. I'm happy to talk about you about
agents,
Haystack, and especially in a sovereign
setting. Thank you.